big picture i showed you this big
picture before we're now going to add to
it
look at what we've done huh electronic
structure
all the way up through you know
accessibility lewis right
molecular orbital theory how to handle
multi electrons
all these different kinds of bonding
check
we've done we've covered every single
one of these and this is solid-state
chemistry
okay but now here we are right now okay
remember
we also talked about some very first
lecture when you classify solids there
are two things that are really important
okay one is the bonding type how do
these
how do the atoms in the solid want to
talk to each other how do they
interact and that is something that we
have covered in a lot of different ways
but the next is how they come together
the actual arrangement of those atoms
and that is
what we're going to talk about today and
on wednesday
and then as we learn after exam two as
we learn about x-rays
that's a way to characterize the
arrangement so that you can see how
they're ordered
okay we're gonna use x-rays and do
something called x-ray diffraction
but for this week for this week
i want to just classify i want to talk
about the things
that the tools that we use to understand
how a solid forms
right how to describe the formation of a
solid
right how how the atoms can be described
and okay so of course a solid is that
which is dimensionally stable
simple definition right but we can break
down
how these atoms arrange into into two
basic categories
okay it's the atomic arrangement the
order
and what we call it right in the first
category
it's regular so what that means is that
everywhere i look
i have the same thing repeating
and and you know what it repeats over a
long
long way like really long
okay so that kind of regular
long range order is a crystal
that's a crystalline solid and that
is going to be the topic of this week
crystalline solids now there are also
solids that you can make where there
isn't order
or maybe there's some but not much so
things are kind of jumbled up they're
not
regularly repeating they might be random
the atomic arrangement or maybe there's
repetition but it's very
short range so things look ordered but
only for a few bond lengths not 10 to
the 23rd bond lengths
right those are called amorphous
solids or also glass
now as i mentioned this is the topic of
this week and this will be covered on
exam two
this is the topic of after exam two
next week okay so we'll talk about both
of these types
of solids as we go all right
now okay it turns out
that nature has been thinking about
order
for a long long time and there's a
reason for this nature
because nature wants to be efficient
this
this plant is like well i'm only going
to grow this big
and i got to put as many seeds as i can
on the surface of this thing
how do i fit them how do i pack them in
well i you know i could fit them
randomly but it doesn't seem like i
could get as many seeds on there
what if i pack them in in some regular
pattern
what if i pack them in in some regular
way
well you can pack a lot more in and so
nature has already been thinking about
symmetry
and order and even long-range order for
a long time
people have been thinking about this too
uh
robert hook the same person from hook's
law
in the 1600s he was all about
cannonballs and he's like
how can i stack cannonballs and you know
he tried this right he's like well
maybe if i just put them like this
is that a good way to stack them i don't
know
uh and then you know he sort of put them
all together
and then but now he tried this and then
he tried another arrangement
and and he'd be like well but how first
of all are they stable
do they fall over easily because you
don't want cannonballs falling all over
the place but then also
did you pack as much in this way as
another way i said he was thinking about
it
and he really he figured out that you
could pack
more cannonballs in for the same area or
volume
if you sort of switched it up right
and then he saw well maybe other things
have packing too and he thought about
all sorts of things he looked at salt
crystals
and he said they must also pack in some
way
because cannonballs do
so people have been thinking about this
for a long time
okay now people are also inspired by
regular order
right so if you look at for example an
escher painting
right you can see that there's a
repetitive pattern here
right this is a crystal of ducks
right now the now when you look at a pat
okay so now when you look at
patterns like this you have to well you
don't have to but we have to in this
class
we got to figure out what is the
repeating unit
what is it that is repeating everywhere
right so that's the first question we
need to ask and you can see if you look
at this picture
you can draw a box like that you know
there's a box around
one a light color dark colored duck and
you and now you see
if you take this box and you move it
over you translate it over there
you get exactly the same thing what if
you take that box and you put it up
there
you get exactly the same thing so that
is a repeating unit
that is a repeating oh we have a
definition
it's a unit cell it's called a unit cell
and it's the repeating unit
in a crystal
it's a repeating unit now it's not
always
obvious right right so there's one way
that i could repeat and make and take
this
and make the picture by repeating it
everywhere but check this out i could
have done that
well if you stare at that you can see
that that is also a repeating unit
right that is also a repeating unit that
that if i take this
and i move it down here i get exactly
the same thing and i move it over there
and i can tile
all of space i can tile all of space
and something is really important here i
can i can
take these repeating units and stamp
them oh i like that word
and and i can and i can tile all the
space and recreate this picture
without any voids right i didn't miss
anything i
filled all of space
i filled all the space and that is what
a crystal system is
right a crystal system let's write it
here a crystal system
crystal system
that is a way of enumerating
enumerates
ways that space can be filled
okay enumerates ways that space can be
filled
with no voids
that's a crystal system okay
well let's go back to the cannons for a
minute because we can we can think about
this
first in 3d before we we're just warming
up before we get to 3d
okay now um okay so oh there it is
that's a unit cell okay now the thing is
so i've drawn a unit cell
and notice what i've done i've taken
this and
i've drawn it this way okay
and those vectors define the unit cell
right those vectors to find the unit
cell so those are my stamps
the vectors there so these things here
well
they went a little far there but they
should go to the center
of the next cannonball so now these are
vectors if i just take these
and i and i and i put them now if i
translate them over to
there then i get this the next unit cell
and the next one and i go up and i go
over and i get all the
tiling of all space and so those vectors
are really important and they have a
name
those are called the lattice vectors
those are the lattice vectors i really
like to think of them
as my stamps or my stamp
it is a stamp
and no voids these vectors are
my stamp now i'm stamping all of space i
didn't really say what i'm putting there
i i mean here there's cannonballs in
escher there's ducks
doesn't matter right now right it's a
stamp that fills all of space
that is how we're building up our
knowledge of crystals okay
well you can also ask the question right
which is how much could you fill in
there
right and that's a very important
question that we want
that we want to know okay
okay now so i've got my lattice vectors
but i want to know
now what am i put you know because i
could put there
i could you know look at this i could
take a lattice vector like this that
this is a
square lattice okay if it's a square
lattice then those are the same length
right a is like the length of the l this
is like the length
of the lattice vector
all right all right now if i if i took
this uh
lattice this stamp and say okay now i'm
gonna decide what to put there
i'm gonna put circles okay so i'm gonna
put a circle there
circle there and what you do then is you
put a circle
everywhere that you stamp
right okay so i have now st
i've now taken my stamp and i've stamped
everywhere and i've put something at
each place
a circle but i might ask a question and
this is a very important question which
is
what is the maximum if i have circles
what is the maximum that they can pack
in for this lattice
how much can i pack to well you can just
visualize that now
let's grow them a stamp
means it's the same thing everywhere
right
so it so now if i make one of them
bigger well i've made them all bigger
right because they're all the same
everywhere
and if i make them all big enough
eventually they're going to touch
like that that's a special thing
because now i've grown the shape that
i'm putting there
to the point where it's the maximum
packing right
and so you know you can imagine this the
area
of maximum packing
is a very important parameter and it's
something that we'll talk about today
with 3d crystals right which is the
solids of
elements in the periodic table
but if you stay with the square analogy
so my lattice is a square my stamp is a
square my sides are equivalent
and what i put there is a circle then
the area of maximum packing is something
you can calculate
right because the the circle itself
in this case if i if i
goes in tight you know if i if i look at
it then
oh that's not a good circle
but anyway you you'll get the point here
which is that
oh boy which is that you know if this is
the lattice vector is
a a right like i do there and i'm
looking at the maximum packing then you
know already
that the radius of the circle is a half
a
so radius equals one half a
right
i mean if the radius of the circle is a
half a
okay if the radius of a circle is a half
a then you also know what the area is
i'm in 2d right now
i'm in 2d so if i've maximized the
packing of these circles on the square
lattice
then the area then the area
area of the circle
is one half
that's a pi times r squared
so one half a squared equals
all right pi a squared over four
but see i also know how much i packed it
in right now i'm doing this slowly
on purpose because we'll go faster when
we do
uh uh some of the other ones but i want
to do the first one
slow because then we'll all be able to
see what we're talking about with the
simplest case the area of the square
is a squared
right and so the the packing the area of
max packing
is equal to
uh okay pi a squared over four
over a squared
pi over four right because the a
squared's cancel
right so it's 78 percent
this is what hook was it but did i max
it out or could i do something different
could i pick a different lattice
what if we made cannonballs into
rectangles bad idea
no he's stuck with spheres but how do
you pack them in how can you
arrange them in a way to change the max
packing that's what nature does
with atoms as we'll see
so for example if i had a 2d hexagonal
lattice
instead of my stamp being a square
so if it were a 2d hexagonal
hexagonal lattice i won't do this one
out
but then the packing the max packing
goes all the way up to 91. 91
that's a lot more per area max packing
max packing right
so this is something that we care a lot
about it's something that we care about
because
i mean this is this is you know when
atoms see each other in a solid
what's the first thing they want to
determine the first thing they want to
do is they want to go back in here and
they want to be like
which one of those can we do can we
can we find some way to bond
that's what atoms do that's what
everyone does how can we bond together
what kind of relationship are we going
to have
they can't do that they want to max that
out right and so they want to try to
pack in
given the bond that they're going to
have and that
is what's going to dictate the kind of
arrangement they can have in the crystal
okay so okay
so here we are and we're going from 2d
to 3d
now the thing is we will not do
uh uh you know this is not going to be
an in-depth
dive into symmetry and space groups
and group theory those are all great
topics
but i'm just going to tell you and it's
actually kind of cool
in 3d there are only seven unique
crystal systems
there are only seven ways that you can
do this you can only pack in
and and have no voids and have no voids
you can only
pack in these seven different systems
where
as you can see what's changing here well
it's cartesian coordinates so you've got
the length of each lattice vector
and their relative angles right that's
all you're changing
well you know sometimes you change all
the angles at once
okay sometimes you change uh only if
well sometimes you change only a few of
them
sometimes you make them all the same
sometimes you change a few sometimes
each you have
all of them be even and sometimes some
of them are equal
some of the lattice lengths are equal
but another one is different
all right these are the seven ways that
we can
fill all of space and there are only
seven
in this class we're only going to focus
on one and that's the cubic system
right and and the reason is that this
gives us plenty
to work with to understand
crystallography
and how chemistry relates to
crystallography and
there's the benefit of the fact that a
lot of elements
take these three take one of these three
actually only two
but they take cubic symmetry what does
that mean
well it means it means
that all the lattice vectors are the
same
each one has a length a they're
orthogonal to each other
right which means that the angle is 90
degrees so we've got a cube
okay now it turns out that now i say
well how do you
pack how can i pack things together
in the cubic system and there
there's three different ways to do it
so what what this is is it's more
symmetry and more group theory and math
that goes into this
that brave figured out and so we call
these brave lattices
now what brave figured out and again you
don't need to know all the math behind
this but i want you to know these
three cubic lattices
what he figured out is that from the
seven crystal systems
there are only 14 ways to pack
there are 14 ways to pack that's it no
more
that's pretty cool there's no 15.
there's no 16 there's 14 exactly 14 ways
that you can by having a lattice which
means a stamp there are only 14 ways you
can do it
for the seven crystal systems and for
the cubic system there's only three
so i have three types of stamp
that's what it means three types of
stamps where
i leave no voids right i leave no void
so i can tile all of 3d space
right okay and it's acute and it forms a
cubic
unit cell cubic unit cell these are the
three ways
a simple cubic a body center cubic
and a face centered cubic these are the
three types
of lattices that have cubic symmetry
they're the only three
so in a brave lattice the difference
is in a brave lattice
what brave did was he enumerated so here
we enumerate the way space can be filled
he enumerated in new meri
the packing all the ways
that the space can be packed with
for example packing within
the unit cell
so there's three distinct ways to pack
within a cubic
unit cell okay so that's what we're
going to bring to life
today and we'll talk more about on
wednesday as well
and what i want to do is i want to go
through each one
so we're going to go through simple
cubic body center cubic face center
cubic
and then um with each one i'm going to
talk about it for a minute and then i'm
going to show you a little video
so that we can really see how the unit
cell gets kind of sliced up and
there's a like a razor that comes in and
slices it it's really cool
and so you can really see and feel
what we're talking about and speaking of
seeing and feeling so i have these
and and i had wanted for these to be
what go in your goody bag but apparently
like a hundred thousand dollars is too
much or whatever
um but uh but so you have smaller
versions of these
and and i encourage you there's no
better way to think about
crystallography than to build stuff
and see it you got to do that it's
really cool and and so these are this is
the uh
uh the simple cubic okay so we'll pass
that around and this is the body
centered cubic
and here you have spheres right
yeah that's fine but in all we've done
so far
is set up a lattice this could be
anything
it's a repeat lattice it's a lattice no
that's what a lattice is
the lattice just defines that this is
the same as this whatever is here
is the same is the same as this is the
same as this
that's what we're defining here okay
yeah
okay all right
now let's talk about
these three these are um this is a
picture from april
these are the three systems i just
talked about the three bravais lattices
three different ways to pack in a in a
in a cubic
symmetric cell and and notice there's
three ways of looking at it right so
here's sort of a ball and stick
model which is easy it makes it easy to
see the bonding and the atoms
but the space filling model is is is
really important here because the space
filling model
lets us think about the maximum packing
that's really important remember the
maximum packing because remember these
are bonding
really these are bonding together
right so drawing them all the way up to
where they touch
right that's going to help us understand
how they pack in how what their maximum
packing can be so let's look at that for
the simple cubic okay
so with a simple cubic we'll do that
here
simple cubic
okay simple cubic
oh let's just call it sc for short why
not
now one of the things you want to think
about is how many nearest neighbors do i
have
and i lost so you can see look at what
look at the edge and think about
how many nearest neighbors are well you
know you got six right if you're in the
corner there
of of the cube and you're simple cubic
you've got six nearest neighbors okay
that's important
right six nearest
neighbors those are
why is that important well it's
important because
that's how many bonds that's how many
other atoms you could bond with
in this solid okay but the other thing
we want to know
is the packing now
again what you want to do to figure out
the maximum packing
is you want to think about it in the
same way we did here
think about putting something at each of
the lattice points
and then growing it out right until they
they can't grow anymore
right that's a good way to think about
it and in this case we're gonna we're
gonna take spheres
we're gonna we're gonna be taking
spheres because that's how we're gonna
represent atoms
okay so we're gonna be taking spheres
and we're gonna grow them out
and see what the packing is yeah but but
i got to do the same trick i did here
i got to do the same trick i did here i
got to write the
the radius of the atom in terms of the
unit cell
so if the unit cell
oh boy i'm gonna be drawing a 3d
structure
danger a a
a it's a cube
all the sides are a i just i made myself
very happy
it's a cube now oh so we're but we have
a cubic
now okay here we go this one oh but see
i want maximum packing so i'm going to
grow them out
and you can see what's going to happen
right as i do that
and so you can see that in the case of a
simple cubic lattice
it's just like in the square lattice
it's just like in the square lattice
right
the when i've grown out the sphere
the radius of that sphere the radius
is r equals
now oh wait a second okay so i have po
four thirds pi or k okay but that
doesn't matter yet don't do volume
think about the radius okay the radius
is just going to be a half the lattice
right so radius is a half a volume
is four thirds pi
a half a cubed
right now this is important that is at
at the max packing
okay so i've grown these volumes out and
i've seen
what the packing can be now we actually
call this you know so now i've got the
volume
of of an atom i'm pretending that these
are atoms now
no i'm not pretending anymore it's real
these spheres are now atoms and
okay so that's the volume of the atom
all right and so we can write atomic
packing fraction
atomic packing fraction now
right as the volume of the atom
over the volume of the cell well that's
exactly what i did up here
right that's how we got right the area
of the square
right the area of the circle right
but there's one more thing that's really
important which is
it has to be times the number of atoms
in the cell when i say cell i mean
unit cell it has to be times the number
of atoms in the unit cell
right so it's however many atoms i have
times the volume of the atom okay that's
good that's how much is
inside of the cell divided by the volume
of the cell and that gives me the atomic
packing fraction so
in the case of a simple cubic the apf
right the atomic packing fraction is
equal to
um pi
over 6 which is 52
that's not very good right that's not
well i mean it's it's relative we don't
know yet but it feels kind of low
52 so with a simple cubic lattice
all i can do in my wildest dreams
is cover 52 of that volume that's not
very
uh that doesn't feel like a lot and in
fact
when you look at the periodic table what
you find is that there's only one
element one that takes the simple cubic
lattice does anybody know what it is
of course it's polonium
of course that's a really good
conversation starter
i'm just saying that is a great way to
meet people
which one is polonium why
relativity relativistic in polonium
those electrons
they're so high energy literally they're
so high energy they're like close to the
speed of light they're
they're relativistic their mass is
heavier all sorts of
interesting things happen polonium's the
only one
that goes simple cubic i promised the
video
oh there's a l oh ha
a a a
there's a diagonal there's another
diagonal
oh we're going to come back to this
let's draw that because that's that
might be important right so
if i have a cube then this diagonal if
that's a
and that's a then that is a root a root
2
and the body diagonal that's the body
diagonal
is a root three not
equals a root three right
okay we'll come back
but i didn't need that because this is
just a over two but
whoa hold on we're coming to it
but i promise the video first so here's
a video with the laser
coming in and you're gonna really see
this will come to life a little bit
of a cube the simple or primitive
cubic unit cell has particles at the
corners only
in reality the particles lie as close to
each other as possible
note that the particles touch along the
cube edges but
not along a diagonal in the face or
along a diagonal through the body
by slicing away parts that belong to
neighboring unit cells we
see that the actual unit cell consists
of
portions of the particles
when the cells pack next to each other
in all three dimensions we obtain the
crystal
if we fade the others out you can see
the original group of eight particles
within the array
and the unit cell within that group we
find the number of particles in one unit
cell by
combining all the particles portions
in the simple cubic unit cell eight
corners
each of which is 1 8 of a particle
combine to give
one particle a key feature of a crystal
structure is its coordination number
the number of the nearest neighbors
surrounding each particle
in a simple cubic array any given
particle has a neighboring particle
above below to the right to the left in
front
and in back of it for a total of six
nearest
neighbors the body-centered cubic unit
cell has a
okay so you see how that's so cool right
like
and you're figuring out how many atoms
are in the cell
right you say well why didn't you just
put the atom in the middle
you could do that but then it's not
at the point right so you got to
understand the concept of the lattice
is that whatever i put here wherever my
vectors go
that's what i put there right and there
and there and and so we often as a
standard we say well okay
what did i put there i put an atom right
and i put another atom but then your
unit cell is that cube
and so we cut the unit cell and you're
like well how many atoms do i have in it
well let's see i got one here but it's
shared with
all these other cubes so there's an
eighth of an atom there right and an
eighth and event on there we add them
all up and you get one atom
right back which you knew which you knew
and by the way this was not one over a
uh uh it was i i wrote it mistakenly
sworn every
the radius is a half a okay over there
all right which was which is correct
here okay good
now next crystal structure oh look
how do you know what crystal structure
and
uh there it is look right there
it's the periodic table to the rescue
again he had it right there
thank you that that
means t-shirts and
t-shirts and t-shirts
and t-shirts and all right i'm going all
the way
up there and up there
we'll bring more you bring a periodic
table like that
what is the crystal symmetry
[Music]
i know which one
is simple cubic polonium where's
it's only polonium a cow there it is
polonium
thank you for being representative of
simple cubic
crystals but now we're talking about the
next kind which is body centered cubic
and look a lot more have a body center
cubic
and here here
okay so if it's bcc body centered cubic
well now you know if i
take these atoms at these corners
and i add now there's a lattice that
takes me to the middle
all right remember my lattice is giving
me this
this symmetry my lattice is giving me
this so
it means whatever i put here i put it
all the corners
and i put in the middle right that's bcc
that's what bcc means well yeah
if you grow that okay so first of all
eight nearest neighbors
right eight nearest neighbors well you
can see that because i've got
the six but then i've got these ones
here right
all right i've got actually it's it's
not the six
i've got the one along the diagonal
which is kind of the point i wanted to
make next
this oh this is bcc this is bcc
right now is it how do you see that it's
bcc
because you stare at it and you stare at
it
you build it you get together with
friends
you get together with friends and you
build even more
and you see how much you can build and
then you look and you see look
here it is there's my square right okay
and there's another square and that's my
cube
and you go like this and then you're
like oh look and there's an atom in the
middle
that's bcc and they're all the same
that's bcc
right but see because this is a lot this
is defined by the lattice
i could have made my square anywhere no
this didn't have to be the middle atom
i could move it over and then this would
be the middle atom
or this right they're all equivalent
it's a lattice now if you look at this
and you take that square or that cube
then then what you'll find is that if
you go along the body diagonal see now
i'm going to take each of these
and i'm going to grow them where do the
atoms touch
if i grow the atoms in a bcc crystal
they touch
along the body diagonal first
now that's really important let's pass
this one around too that's really
important
okay because now
we have this this concept
that is also very important
which is the closed pack direction
close packed
direction
and for this for the bcc structure
it's the body diagonal
but over here it's the cube edge for a
simple cubic
it's the cube edge cube edge
is the closed packed okay how is that
going to work
i'll do this that
no that's going to be confusing cube
edge
close packed
oh that's really small but you get my
point close packed
direction close pack direction body
diagonal what that what that means is
that
you know and and you can see it right
here where's the
you know if you go back all the way back
to this there it is
let's see as i grow these these are the
same they're colored blue just for
clarity
just so you can see but these are the
same because it's a bcc lattice and as i
grow them these all have the same radius
these are the ones that touch first
along the diagonal not those
right not those and that feeds into what
the radius is
of the atom i do the same trick and the
apf
and the apf is going to be
okay four thirds pi
and now i've got my a root three
over 4. why because
a is the length of the cube and you can
see here i've got
four radii right two diameters
of the sphere go down the body diagonal
so r cubed four thirds pi r cubed
is going to be the volume of
a maximally packed sphere in a bcc
lattice
so this has to be divided by the whole
volume
which is a cubed but i'm missing
something
because there's not just one right
there's not just one there's another one
there's actually two atoms in a unit
cell
there's two of these you can see that
one in the middle and then the eighth
eighth a they they
you've got two so i got to multiply it
by
two and it gives you sixty eight percent
is the af app and that's why so many
more
structures especially metals are happy
to be bcc
let's watch the video again or a
different video this one on bcc
particle at each corner and one in the
center
which is colored pink to make it easier
to see
with full size spheres you can see that
the particles don't touch along the
edges of the cube
but each corner particle does touch the
one
in the center the actual unit cell
consists of portions of the corner
particles
and the whole one in the center eight
eighths
give one particle and the one in the
center gives
another for a total of two particles
in this tiny portion of a body-centered
cubic array
you can see that any given particle has
four
nearest neighbors above and four below
for a total of eight
nearest neighbors okay now it's really
important right that's
this you see conceptually visually how
we got this the close pack direction
for bcc is four times the radius i want
to write that
four times the radius
and it's that it's that thing that we're
doing now a couple of times right where
you
you've got the radius of this sphere
that you're packing in
with a given symmetry but i got to write
that
in terms of the lattice vectors
which are in this case all a right so
it's really easy but but they're all a
so
i got to write it in terms of the length
of the lattice that's how you get the
atomic packing
okay good now
the last one is fcc look at how many
elements take the fcc form
how do you know you bring out the
periodic table
and you look it up now some of these i
mean many of these elements can take
different crystal symmetries the ones
that are listed are the ones
that are often always the most stable
one
right the most stable one but sometimes
they can take many different
symmetries if you do something like add
temperature
or pressure or other things to the
system what's in the periodic table is
the most stable one
now the fcc the fcc is the last one that
we're
going to care about and it
is the face centered cubic
now this is okay so on this one uh
we got an atom this is the face
right so we've got these atoms that are
sharing
across the face and then we've got these
atoms here
right at the corners there's nothing in
the middle now
but they're on the faces and sorry the
corners and the faces
right and so if you if you
look at this what you can see from
looking at this and you've got to look
at it
where's my cube where's my unit cell you
now know it's called the unit cell
right oh and i see and then there's the
face atom right there's
there's a square there and there's the
atom in the face
and there's nothing in the middle it's
not bcc
right but if i look at another and
another edge of that
ah right there's the atom in that face
and so on and so on
right now what's really cool about fcc
is that it's got a lot of neighbors and
it's got
more packing so for fcc
this is the closed pack direction
close pack
direction is
the face is the did i write down
i didn't write down okay that's fine
it's the face diagonal face diagonal
right which is a root 2 in
length and so the atomic packing so the
nearest neighbors is 12
and the atomic packing fraction for fcc
is four-thirds pi
times and now here we go right that's
when i expand them it's along the face
that they're going to touch
right so that's the close-packed
direction face diagonal
that's this one here right so it's root
it's a
root 2 over four
right because again i've got a radius
and another and another and another i
can you know there's two diameters worth
that go across that face and so that's
going to be
cubed yeah okay divided by a cubed now
is there something missing
yes the number of atoms
if you look at a fcc crystal and
and you look at the corners each one of
those shares with eight
other unit cells so there's an eighth
that gives you the one
like in our simple cubic but now you got
all these ones sharing across faces
you've got six of those each one sharing
a half atom
so that's three more so there's four
and this gives you a very nice
packing of 74
74 let's see what our video guy says
about fcc
ah the face centered cubic unit cell has
a particle at each corner
and in each face which are colored
yellow here
but none in the center the corner
particles don't touch each other
but each corner does touch a particle in
the face
and those in the faces touch each other
as well
the actual unit cell consists of
portions of particles at the corners and
in the faces
eight eighths at the corners gives one
particle
and half a particle in each of six faces
gives
three more for a total of four particles
in this tiny portion of a face-centered
cubic array
notice that a given particle has four
nearest
neighbors around it four more above and
four more below for a total of twelve
nearest neighbors stacking spheres shows
how the three cubic unit cells are
talking about packing arrange a layer of
spheres in horizontal and vertical rows
note the large diamond shape space among
the particles
placing the next layer directly over the
first
gives a structure based on the simple
cubic unit cell
those larger spaces mean an inefficient
use of space
in fact only 52 percent of the available
volume
is actually occupied by spheres
because of this inefficiency the simple
cubic unit cell is seen
rarely in nature polonium a more
efficient stacking occurs if we place
the second layer
over the spaces formed by the first
layer and the third layer over the space
is formed by the second
that simple change leads to 68 percent
of the available volume occupied by the
spheres
and a structure based on the
body-centered cubic unit cell
many metals including all the alkali
metals adopt this arrangement
for the most efficient stacking shift
every other row in the first
layer so the large diamond shaped spaces
become
smaller triangular spaces and place the
second layer
over them then the third layer goes
over the holes visible through the first
and second layers
in this arrangement called cubic closest
packing spheres occupy 74
of the volume note that it is based
on the fcc crystal brave lattice that's
what he meant to say there
and you really see it come to life right
i wish i could do this somehow with the
3d models
but you stir it to 3d models you see
that you know what's interesting is
the way you put it you you re you slide
this is what hook did with the cannon
balls you slide that base layer
and then you can stack them differently
but it's still a cubic system
fcc all right we'll pick up on this
on wednesday
you